[Music]
Boal Star Wars trilogy created by AI
this is the one wheel pretty much the
best electric vehicle that's not a car
I've put well over 3,000 miles on this
thing now obviously I didn't do all
those miles on one single charge this is
actually the first generation one wheel
which only has a range of about six
miles and that's great for just riding
around town but once you put a few miles
on you guys start looking for a place to
charge unless you do what I do and use a
mobile charging solution to charge while
you're out in the field like this
a solar controller using a solar
controller you can feed energy from any
battery into the one-wheel so my buddy
Ian actually took this to the next level
and packaged that into a self-contained
charging solution on the go called car
of power it's pretty sweet and works
really well this is the exact system I
use when I'm actually out on a mountain
or in the field wherever I am away from
a power outlet and I still need to
charge the one wheel I've seen comments
on that mountain video asking whether or
not I can charge while riding
I've always responded no you cannot
charge and ride at the same time it's
not possible except that it's possible
it's very possible and I'm gonna try it
now the charger that holds into the one
wheel uses what's called an XLR ports
the Chargers XLR port actually has three
pins on the inside of it but here's the
thing you only actually need two of
those pins to charge the one wheel the
third pen is literally just there to
inform the one wheel whether or not it
is plugged in and to not turn on if it
is now obviously you don't want a
situation where it's plugged in and the
one wheel turns on and thinks that it's
operational even though it's there
tethered to a wall so that's where this
mod comes in if you disconnect that
third pin the one will doesn't actually
know that it's no longer plugged into
the wall even though it will still be
able to receive power that's critical to
this mod so it's actually happening here
is that we're fooling the one wheel into
believing that it's getting regenerative
energy by going downhill even
that's not the case at all now I want to
clarify that this video is not a
tutorial and then if you decide to try
this too you run the risk of ruining
your board and even worse perhaps having
it turn off min ride which can cause
considerable injury so I don't recommend
you actually try this you have been
warned
there's a huge deadline looming behind
us it's like that for scope names behind
the main characters this piece the blue
zone shrinking in width at deliver a
trailer the end of this week we have to
have gold cut lock tab in this week and
then next week is our week's finished
all the effects all the sound all the
music and then it comes out seems like
there's a faster schedule than most but
what if I told you that this is out all
CD videos are done on a reckless
neck-breaking schedule like this one
times kind of line
yeah it's faster the most but you know
what this is totally not through Matic
way to end this segment but I believe in
our team and we do a good job here at
corridor we try to have a drama-free
environment where we actually get our
work done on time and provide the
artists the support they need to do the
work because Nico's not talking about
this correct way at all if we don't have
this edit locked by Friday then
basically the client hates us and
they'll never bring us another really
cool grand integration like pub G
[Music]
don't mess it up this guy sent us an
email who doesn't want to work on a Star
Wars movie when your kid Tony who
watches our YouTube channel Peter guard
us was messing around and created a
neural network that creates star wars
movie scripts that's right an AI making
a Star Wars movie script he sent us one
look how long this is really great kind
of like they send us that and I was like
you made an AI neural network that sends
this movie scripts sent us two more
right now and he sent two more a full
Star Wars trilogy created by AI it's
like as if r2d2 decided to become a
writer there's dialogue oh yeah interior
[ __ ] valet day you wanna walk down to
into room around the cheer - artoo you
must - one with one hand said time
obi-wan how losts diddle annie is a pods
they need any down you they begin to
confident Padme its report the Force
Commander West's the elevate the nest
for you we have taken of the love nute
Gunray is ship around
Palpatine no in this approach fear the
force and Queen is the rocking then the
bridge for a colouring Li it's absolute
gibberish anyways I made extra spicy
chili ghost pepper lava chili homemade
you know most video game companies have
something called the crunch time you
know where like all the employees come
into my 80 hours a week working in video
games and just used to the accepted
practice in the industry well at
Infinity Ward back in the days of making
cult like call of duty 4 modern warfare
1 modern warfare 2 etc I actually have a
chance to speak to the devs and they're
like yeah we don't do crunch time we
just properly manage our projects that's
we do here we just properly manage our
projects
[Applause]
it's coming together you're doing did a
pretty solid job at picking out some
really good character beats and you
beginning and even the fight scenes
coming together anyway yep and I'm
excited for this mod I want to ride
forever or as long as my batteries will
allow so the most common form a battery
to charge on the go is this thing it's a
10 cell battery
Thank You China this is actually the
same exact battery you'll find on the
inside of those classic like two-wheel
hoverboard scooter things that don't
have any name so everyone was causing
the hoverboard even though they don't
hover boom and now it's charging unplug
it done you don't need any special
balancing that's all done internally
that's the nice thing about these
batteries comparing that with say a
light boat battery this has a lot more
energy but as you can see is unprotected
boughs the Pierces with something it may
explode like in this video
[Applause]
for this mod there are two main things
we're going to adjust and that's
basically we're gonna disconnect that
third pin inside of this plug and also
extend the length of this cable I'm
gonna use just like a classic little
laptop cable to I can I can jump rope to
this Jeff scissors know this is gonna
feel very weird I'm gonna cut the tip of
this off
there's something about cutting
electrical cords like this with scissors
that just feels so wrong oh that was
that was dirty now to cut the other end
off so the reason why I did that is
because I only need the two wires in
this cable the one's a negative one's a
positive terminal and I'm gonna start
her some xt60 connectors to the ends of
these so for the put really the second
part is a very specific 90 degree angle
XLR Court in the event that you do crash
or spill it won't roll over and break
the port you can actually choose what
angle this goes in at I'm gonna rip out
one of these pins I'm gonna solder the
two wires to the other two pens in
theory this should work
time for some soldering that was very
scary I'm decent at soldering now I'm
not worried about that I am worried
about potentially ruining the one-wheel
if this is up and running
only a little bit worried it's about
that time where I tell you guys about
the beautiful wonderful world of squirt
space that's right this segment is
sponsored by Squarespace and once again
I'm here to tell you just how simple and
amazing it has been for the corridor
digital dot-com website you may have
noticed that 2018 brought in a slightly
new website that I'm pretty proud of you
see these do you see these you see these
beautiful little scrolling backgrounds
before it was like this
they were static it always bothered me
that I couldn't get the background to
scroll as you know Squarespace has
beautiful award-winning templates now
what does that mean you can bring your
website from one template over to
another giving it a completely different
look and feel without having to change a
thing about your account or anything
else let me show you how this works
I found a template that I liked one that
still got stood out to me Senhora I
clicked preview it took all the
information from our current website it
brought it over into that template to
them now we have the new one the only
thing that was holding me back was
myself because it's where
has an all-in-one platform there's
nothing to install patch or upgrade ever
meaning that your site all over will
always be up to date also if you are
looking for a domain and you don't want
to do domain hosting and web site
hosting he'll take care of all that for
you as well so anyway you know how this
works go to Squarespace comm slash Sam
and Nico and you get 10% off your first
purchase it's that simple
you're welcome so it has been a weekend
I have taken this home and I just tested
to see if it works I realized I needed
some way to mount this thing to my
backpack so what I did was I literally
just took some gaff tape and basically
made a rope out of it so this is
literally just hanging on the back of my
backpack uses some gaff tape and some
string that was left over from our couch
pillows hello
pillows you know what this is this is
all a little on the janky side I needed
a way to mount this green meanie to the
back of my backpack my 3d model in
fusion 360 a holder or this and ppt all
the holes line up how about I just go
ahead and just put these screws in mount
this thing up and done it works there
are few things more satisfying in life
than when you model something and print
it and now it's real and it's useful
it's working so here is the finished
plug and you see my I got my little
quick-release support here so when I
fall off it just unplugs it doesn't do
any damage doesn't get tangled up at all
so here's another problem that I've run
into if I crash and it rolls onto its
side all the impact force goes straight
into the plug and the plug itself is not
designed to take that sort of impact
there's the space between the actual
plug itself in the rest of the one-wheel
so if I press here all the force from
that pressing goes into the plug instead
of the board what people have done
online is that they actually buy these
bushings and you literally just put it
on like that and this is supposed to
protect the plug from your crashes the
problem is that this bushing is far too
large and that it doesn't actually get a
good seat into the plug it falls out
really easily so that's problem the plug
could break off inside and the entire
one wheel is just dead so what I did was
actually 3d model another part and 3d
printed that today and this was the
original V 1 this is the V 2 you want to
see something super satisfying so
put this on here and then plug this in
this should be able to take an impact
and not damage anything I haven't done
an actual proper test with this thing
yet and actually want to compare it up
against something that's actually really
good and can go the distance such as
jams one-wheel XR I'm really intrigued
to see if we can both ride from my home
to the studio tomorrow and see which one
of us will make it
Jan is very skeptical of my experience
with batteries
[Music]
if I picked it up like if I drop this is
that now literate since I grabbed it Jen
I unfortunately think that would be
littering taking on the responsibility
that to a trash can that's life
sometimes you help people get a bag
don't let her folks even if it means
carrying a bag with you for two and a
half miles
it's renas testing his new one wheel mod
problem is his test involves writing all
the way to the studio riding all the way
to the studio with Jan Jen has never
come into the studio without attack what
did we just wrote all the way here from
Pasadena yeah
and they're on they're coming right now
one of the traps yeah dude the mugwort I
went 15.1 miles and I still have 74%
battery left but it worked man we made
all the way here it took us a couple
hours but we made it dude everyone's
here today we add up the whole flanking
maneuver setup so the moment that door
open they came in we went around let's
roll in no I heard you roll in the Steve
warned us Stephen I saw Stephen I
couldn't see who it was I just knew guys
were coming down the street and if I had
my camera I would have done it in
slow-mo because it looked like Reservoir
Dogs whether you have your own 3d
printer you have a service that you want
to go through I will make these publicly
available for free for you to download
if you want